[Musique]
mais pourquoi vous garez vous dans mon
allée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais donc tester un
nouveau jeu il s'agit de barbie
détective non c'est pas ça du tout il
est où je vends je n'y arrive à
commencer le temps d'y aller
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
bon bien sus de space mutins ont sorti
en 1991 sur nes ce jeu est horrible il
va voler mon enfance dit pas envie d'en
parler non c'est juste à 300 mètres
d'ici bas à tester bon le jeu sorti sur
tous les supports de les plans qu'il
s'agit d'un jeu de plates formes
classiques mais avec quelques subtilités
en fait quand je dis subtilité je
devrais plutôt dire piège syndic qui on
veut rendre fou alors l'histoire ce sont
des extraterrestres d'été d'ailleurs au
passage euh c'est quoi ces tronches les
prix n'ont pas pris quand du co2 comme
dans la série isma fut bref et donc ils
veulent construire une armée pour ça ils
ont besoin de trucs pour
et donc pour sauver le monde bargues
décide de repeindre tous les objets de
viol et de free fils parce que tous les
objets violet du monde fonta springfield
c'est logique
alors pour certains c'est assez simple
pour d'autres il faut réfléchir un peu
plus alors heureusement bart est
quelqu'un de courageux parce que les
rues sont envahies de poule qui saute
sur place ne soit pas l'air de choquer
les habitants enfin moi quand même si je
sortais de chez moi et que je voyais des
calamars qu'il faut une gigue irlandaise
sur le trottoir je pense que je
rentrerai direct comme les passages de
saut entre les poupe c'est vraiment la
partie sous lens regarde faire garder la
tête des poules quand dirais même ils
sont gavés date dans le jeu aïe aïe aïe
voilà c'est là ça y est on y est on
arrive au coeur du problème du jeu c
c'est vrai c'est vraiment pour ça que
j'ai pas envie d'y rejouer les contrôles
de ce jeu sont absolument misérable
d'armé sont comme une vieille cas de
l'afrique
prenons mario par exemple la base du jeu
c'est quand même de pouvoir sauter en
sprintant là les mecs qui ont fait les
simpson ils se sont dit eux allaient
nous on va pas faire pareil on va mettre
les deux sur le bouton du coup vous êtes
au petit filet dès que vous arrivez
devant un ennemi pour pouvoir faire un
saut un super saut le sprint de saharien
d'ailleurs pour faire un super saut il
faut appuyer sur a + b en même temps et
b c'est le bouton qui vous permet de
tirer quand vous avez une arme alors
pour la bombe de peinture du premier
niveau c'est pas trop grave mais dans le
niveau suivant vos munitions sur limitée
et là du coup mais ça veut dire que vous
en faire des buts à chaque fois que vous
sautez alors heureusement il ya un moyen
de contourner le problème c'est de
maîtriser la tactique des sceaux à
l'envers et avec ça mais tout devient
super facile ouais ça c'est la maîtrise
regarder ça pourquoi de moi que j'arrive
par a pourquoi qu'elle soit plus que je
veux faire quand je veux tester le jeu
[Musique]
la petite différence de ce jeu par
rapport à des placements de classiques
c'est que tu peux acheter et utiliser
certains objets genre lui-même par
exemple qui sont de base et qui te font
différencier les humains des
extraterrestres au nom je dépensais
belge ivo
non c'est un humain je suis mort quoi
aimer sérieusement tu passes à côté d'un
extraterrestre ou touchent même pas mais
par contre si toi tu touches un e-mail
will depuis direct kouame ans vivrait
dans ce monde de merde quoi
quand tu connais pas le jeu des bulles
que tu connais pas un jeu tu le test fut
tout au hasard jeté des bombes sur des
amis ça te semblerait logique et
maintenant le siffler ça ça en rien par
faire venir un chien pour te tuer
sérieusement le vendeur il aurait autant
pu me vendre une lame pour m'ouvrir les
veines ça aurait été pareil à ce
compte-là léman il utile je sais pas à
quoi ça sert
foot que j'aime approuvé les feux
d'artifice à ou alors ça c'est le mieux
les feux artifices il faut s'en servir
par exemple pour allumer un néon qui
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs voilà et j'en
ai plus [ __ ] il me reste deux rideaux
à fermer pour finir le niveau et j'ai
pris une fusée voilà j'ai plus qu'à
repartir au tout début pour en acheter
[Musique]
et tout le trajet l'enverra refaire
esquiver les poulpes abominable c'est à
france
mais vous savez on m'avait offert ça
pour noël quand j'avais 10 ans et
imagine comme je me suis fait 40 un peu
ce genre de choses c'était fréquent
l'époque on ne pouvez jamais savoir si
un jeu est tellement avant dix à vingt
jours du poison
merci maman je suis annuel mon petit
grenier
[Musique]
l'âge et les fusées maintenant de
nouveau dans l'autre sens c'est
[Musique]
euh quoi
bbb pourquoi non mais tu sais qui tu
veux bien m'excuser ça fait dix secondes
[Musique]
bon
à
alors je ramène le jeu au magasin et
après je me tue z'avez match aller je
dirais tu si tu veux jouer injuste ce
n'est que juste une course aux plus
récentes
[Musique]
xbox
toujours je te fais ce jeu je savais que
tu l'aimés
[Musique]
bombe à partir du niveau 2 dans les
niveaux suivants récupérer les objectifs
ça devient quand même un peu plus facile
vous voyez par exemple est largement
plus de chapeau que nécessaire d'un
niveau 2 dans le niveau 3 il faut
récupérer des ballons le d'ailleurs une
astuce une astuce qui est pas forcément
très connu au début dans le jeu des
balles en fait il suffit de rater
volontairement le jeu qui vous demandent
de crever trois ballons de la même
couleur en crevant de bleu et rouge par
exemple et vous pouvez recommencer quand
vous avez des pièces ça vous fait autant
de ballons en bois récupérés c'est utile
mais bon moi comme suit un clochard que
j'ai que deux pièces
ça me sert à rien dans le niveau 3 aussi
à plein d'autres mini-jeux
je fais ça voila voila je n'ai rien pigé
regardez moi cette bande de pervers là
qu'ils ont foutu une filiale au dessus
du gouffre où ça va trois chances sur
quatre de crever en voulant apparemment
moi je vais je vais tenter parce que
j'ai pas le choix vous allez allez ah
oui oh non c'est pas vrai dans les
abysses et sans déconner quand vous
voyez une vie comme ça même si elles
sont super dur à choper vous êtes
obligés de courir après mais quand je
dis alors mais quand je dis courir après
c'est vraiment courir après parce
qu'alors je sais pas si les développeurs
ont été des enfants battus dans leur
jeunesse et qu'ils ont eut décidé de se
venger sur les gosses à travers ce jeu
mais quand vous voyez une vie la vie ce
bar cc c'est la première fois que je
vois ça dans un jeu un item qui s'enfuit
quand ils vous voient quoi mais revient
respect de saloperies
le niveau 4 mai cf c'est un peu en fait
c'est un best-of de tout ce qui est
chiant dans le jeu or déjà pour
commencer ce niveau il est interminable
alors tu achète d'abord le musée plus la
gêne un gouffre l'egypte renommer le
musée de nouveau la planète mars avec
des dinosaures et après de nouveau le
musée mais c'est chaque fois que tu
arrives à une section à la fin d'une
section que tu te lis ou salé c'est fini
eh ben non en fait ça continue encore et
encore si avec eux ça jeudi par des
médias dans ce niveau mais y est mais
tout est délirant déjà pour l'objectif
les panneaux exit a récupéré sa demande
mais ça demande des sommets
mais très et il ya ces items la dernier
par les vitrines aulas j'ai besoin de
filmer l'espèce jamais regardé sans dire
que 20 des mises là pour vous narguer je
sais ce genre de utah besoin d'une vie
mais qui m'aura pas bébé l'écossais pour
sortir ses traits au bordel à tanger
comment j'ai fait
[Musique]
mais le pire c'est aussi le pire c'est
le level design se lèveront on passe on
passe des sceaux durée vicieux rosso 10e
est buggé ce passage là [ __ ] je ne
supporte pas ce passage
mais merde comme les [ __ ] d'oiseaux
mais tenez mais comment tu veux passer
ça il est pas visible avant d'avoir déjà
sauté les deuxième tentative
allez l'oiseau ce coup ci tu me pose
c'est bon allez là c'est moi je commence
à gérer d'athènes de skate c'est sa
demande d sommet des dix plus de
précisions ouais voilà allez ensuite
bien mais non voyons je peux pas croire
ça je suis passé mais complètement au
travers
mais non mon dieu il a descendu sous les
pieds bart en plus ça se passe ce
passage ce passage avec les squelettes
c'est le passage qui m'a fait stopper le
jeu la première fois et et quand tu
meurs mais ça dure dix ans que tu sais
histoire que tu es bien le temps de te
voir souffrir de peu de savourer thabor
[Musique]
vous
du pur sadisme bon vous me connaissez je
suis pas du genre à aller pour rien bon
mais là ce passage de jeu il est juste
obscène jeudi pourtant filer une
guêpière et aller se faire fouetter par
des vieux perdait un temps que je joue à
ce jeu et ça quand je fais comment la
[ __ ] j'ai plus d'arbres génial les
mini boss en général ça c'est simple il
faut j'espère sauter dessus mais mais là
c'est vrai je fais quoi
ne me dites pas qu'il faut avoir besoin
de l'homme je n'ai jamais eu besoin
jusqu'à présent en fait je veux pas
crever au portel c'est quoi ça mais on
peut sauter sur la perspective du décor
mais en fait mais c'est n'importe quoi
messi c'est fou quoi mais c'est un jeu
de blues bar faire un arrêt sur image
l'ajout montre vous êtes là comment est
ce que vous pouvez imaginer sauter ici
ça a l'air d'être à 5 ans m ou alors la
logique voudrait que bart deviennent
plus petits vieux vue qui s'éloigne du
premier plan mais mais la mort là c'est
comme si en fait bas march sur un décor
qui est verticalement collée sur le mur
mais c'est un paradoxe de la kz2 n ya
plus de profondeur
bon ben je crois qu'on va faire une
pause
[Musique]
oh
mon médecin m'a dit que finir rapidement
ce test donc de quoi je peux vous parler
peut vous parler de la musique des boss
qui en fait le thème de la mort qui est
mise en bouche
ou alors du moment vous devez aller
chercher des angles dans le dd statut
pour faire grossir une crotte qui vous
permet d'avancer
qu'est ce qu'on se marre
[Musique]
tu restes là si tu veux mais moi je veux
voir le dernier niveau se passe dans la
centrale nucléaire et bar doit récupérer
seize barres d'uranium
or déjà autant vous dire que si bart se
trimballe avec des barres d'uranium dans
ses poches je pense qu'il va profiter
très longtemps que la victoire il faut
ramener les barreaux sous sol de la
centrale sauf que vous pouvez évidemment
remporté que quatre à la fois ce qui
vous foncent à faire des allers retours
on peut bien les rendra marge mais cette
cruche on dirait qu'elle vous évite aux
m'a dit tu peux m'aider
non bon ben vas te faire [ __ ] là
maintenant imaginez imaginer comment
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait rendre ce
niveau encore plus chiant mais c'est
simple en foutant labyrinthe parce que
ce niveau c'est cela
chaque étage possède un code de sécurité
alors il faut noter les codes sur des
post it pour pas les oublier alors il
faut prendre l'ascenseur qui vous mène
un escalier qui vous mène à un autre
ascenseur pour récupérer les bars en
notant l'école en sautant par dessus des
millions de boules mais je reviendrai m
j'ai mis aucune colle je cherchais
partout n'ai aucun code sur ce jeu bien
venir
le pire c'est qu'il n'y a aucun mot de
passe le jeu qui allume la console tu ne
t'arrêtes pas tant que tu n'as pas fini
le jeu en entier
tu le v2 seul trait
fabre bref pour résumer en fait c'est
nul saleté de mutants saleté de jeu je
ne veux plus jamais te renvoie
[Musique]
tiens
alors uma comme sony des saletés de
mutants un salut bien besoin
on sait pas ce que c'est mais de toucher
passe à mieux vous êtes un malade
[Musique]
vous avez détruit le supermarché
arrêtez de toucher à pau celui là n'ont
pu y est pas là dessus donc se tient
jetez moi ça donne du ballet
[Musique]
ne je ne comprends pas pourquoi tout le
monde sait influent sur ce jeu il est
pourtant pas si mal
je n'en sais rien je ne les jamais testé
mail pour voir dans les temps d'accueil
de l'empereur kanak tuque c'est quoi ce
soap n'arrive pas à sauter ce serait que
devrait être interdit par la promotion
de plus sans transition le joueur du
grenier figure locale des jeux vidéo que
l'on voit ici sur une photo
d'archives/reuters la compagnie d'agra
feu
l'intéressé n'a pas su nous donner une
réponse valable quant aux motifs de son
acte aussi étrange qu'inutile merci
d'avoir visionné cette vidéo
et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne c'était kent brockman en direct
d'un village au nom imprononçable du sud
de la france
couach et tu me dis pas chute à moi moi
je te casse la tête